you're a small business owner here's how  you break through your plateaus you find  people who know more than you do and  here's why because you probably got to  this point because you've brought people  in taught them everything you know  brought another person and taught them  everything you know and you can do all  their job better than them but at the  point that you plateau is where you've  run out of ideas and the business is the  accumulation of all the best ideas in  the business but if they all come from  you it's only from one brain and so at  that point when you hit this plateau is  when you need to bring other people in  who have experience and knowledge that  you don't have and as soon as you have  that it expands the roof of the business  because now it's not based on one brain  but many